I am nyan chanda on the Ile center for
the state
and we are dealer
our studios ambassador use of giada the
Consul General of Egypt in New York mr.
consul general welcome thank you so
thanks for making this time for us the
first the easy question how does it feel
to be presenting a government in
transition what how does it know is a
lake well it feels good and bad at the
same time good because each went through
a wonderful transition a transition that
just removed a heavy burden on his
shoulders I mean you know we were
suffering from frustration frustration
from everything from inadequate housing
drinking water public transportation you
name it so I see this revolution against
frustration if you like but at the same
time transitional governments and
transitional periods in general it's a
bit worrying because you know you have
so many things going on it's many people
differing in opinions and remember the
Egyptian revolution was a revolution
without a leader it was the popular
revolution by the masses so here we
don't have a little opposition like what
happened in some other countries that
experience that so it's a it's very
fluid and the fluidity creates
uncertainty as to definitely yeah how to
how to react to certain situation now
because this is a transitional
government what kind of brief do you
have from Cairo as to how one of the
things that have changed from the past
in terms of your conduct well one of the
good things that changed is that you
don't have a corruption as you did
before because you had a huge gap
between the haves and the have-nots I
mean is it is of course in many
countries the same case but in Egypt
that was linked with politics so if you
have and you're powerful I mean the rich
and powerful rule the whole place and
the masses were just neglected and we
have people who are living in hands
columns because of
because of this at the time the Egyptian
economy was booming with am president
that numbers for tourists saw you would
trade with the world foreign direct
investments and all that and at the same
time people were getting poorer so this
was the imbalance there was something
wrong happening so in terms of foreign
policy in terms of dealing with other
countries institutions you have no new
directive from Cairo you are carrying on
as if it was the past or no of course
not because you're not having
instructions as before from an
autocratic government you're allowed now
to say your opinion your opinion is
being considered every time for example
just give you simple examples right to
vote for Egyptians abroad I mean this is
a big issue Egyptians living in other
countries outside Egypt are longing for
pot space with your participation
they've been neglected and deprived of
this right for years and now we have
certain websites Facebook things and all
that about a right to vote for Egyptians
and of course you weep me as an
ambassador I was asked by the government
there transitional government about
Mothma my opinion if this happens how
are we going to manage our opening
ballots for the Egyptians abroad here so
this is how it works I mean you're being
asked about European about something
they take any consideration is quite
different than before so that's a very
important change that you are you are
part of the policy-making process in
that sense yes you are giving you an
input and they're considering it of them
right yeah that's very interesting now
in terms of relationship with in Israel
that has been a key element of Israel
egypt's foreign policy and there have
been some changes but the development of
the release of this israeli prisoner
with the mediation of Egypt I understand
of this is creating a new situation so
what's your thoughts about the prospect
of Egypt Israel additions
future firstly I'd like to congratulate
best rated people for getting back good
actually it was a young man isn't doing
anything just served in the Israeli
Defense Forces and abducted by Hamas
five years ago because of course all the
animosity between both parties now with
the Egyptian mediation we managed to
free 400 plus presence and hopefully 700
more in the weeks and days to come so
this is a good step by gyptian mediation
what did we do we have good relations
with Hamas and the same time we have
good relations with Israel our neighbors
and as everybody knows we have these
peace accords signed with israel since
march 1979 and we are willing to respect
these peace accords because it is
important to live in peace with your
neighbor I mean we already had our wars
and differences and now we changed our
policies with Israel from war policy to
a piece broker actually Egypt is helping
the peace negotiations with the quartet
with the negotiations between the PA
Palestinian Authority and Israel so I
think relations with Israel have to go
on business as usual what people keep
saying about mubarak being the main
safeguard to this I don't believe this
we as Egyptians believed that our
relations with our neighbors are
important and we're going to safeguard
it for the sake of everybody yeah but
also I think with the improved relations
with with Hamas you may have even a
stronger hand in as a mediator you
definitely yes because if you can talk
to both sides at the same time why not I
mean we already had they had relations
with Palestinians as you've just
mentioned we have better listen with
Hamas after Mubarak to Jim went also
went away so thing is you can play
better role as a mediator I think this
is in the interest of everybody yeah
Egypt has been since the 50s has been
the kind of leader in the Arab world
Egyptian model Egyptian political
ideology were accepted followed by
millions of violent people so how do you
see Egypt carrying on that role now in
this post Arab Spring
volition yes this is a very important
question because Egyptians were
wondering what happened to their image
if you like in the Arab world I mean
when NASA was there in the 50s and 60s
until the late sixties another one
alastair that came with this glorious
burst personality and has links with lea
with the West Nala mean things starting
by moving but of course when when the
peace treaty was brokered with Israel
many Arab countries boycotted Egypt for
some time until we had unfortunately the
assassination of the president in six
october six 1981 and now i think in
Mubarak's era things happen with the
Egyptian influence in the Arab world I
mean it was sort of replaced by a salvi
role with respect or Francis on this by
Turkish role even somebody who's not in
the arable when Iranian troll I mean
Iran Turkey and Saudi Arabia but playing
the role that Egypt should have been
part of us and it was the private of it
because of Mubarak policies of self
containment and uh well just playing
lazy so we couldn't participate in
anything that was happening around us
unfortunately now i think we have a
different perspective of things we are
cooperating with many countries as
you've seen the cooperation with turkey
lately course turkey has some
differences now with israel but again as
you mentioned earlier we can play all so
wrong that and the turkeys turkish model
of a democracy where the military kind
of stays in the background and political
electric electro fischels around the
country is that model going to be
applied to egypt or is it do you think
there will be different model in Egypt
well some people have been talking about
following the Turkish model of the
secular state Nala I mean Egypt is
different because people but we also we
have the Coptic population I mean a
third of the population or quarterly
population of Egypt questions questions
and this is something that Egypt has
characterized with different than many
other countries with the exception
perhaps of the Palestinians and
countries like Lebanon so and of course
Gyptian cops are very important these
are the original Egyptians when Islam
came to
to the country they were there these are
the oranges of Egypt and we're very
proud of our Egyptian gods so thing is
if you have the if you have to place a
caring role you have to get in
concentration also the privileges and
the rights of the two faiths
Christianity and Islam and this is not
very easy in light of the rise of many
Islamic rigid thoughts as you as we've
seen worldwide not only in Egypt so I
think you have a rather unique saw
responsibility of leading this
democratic development in a way that is
secular at the same time respects the
country's the fates that their desires
right I wouldn't use the word secular we
were trying to place that with the civil
state ok using a civil state term means
that you can have a state which respects
all faiths equally and this is of course
an ambition and I think they're working
on it now as you know scaf which is the
Supreme Council of Armed Forces ruling
the country it has been chosen by you
know but by a sort of when the when we
overthrew the the regime of Mubarak the
army of the Armed Forces found itself
there whether they like it or not
because there was no other option and of
course Egyptians have this experience of
1952 when they have Nasser with the
military coup all that and at that time
they call it revolution that was the 50s
we don't like to look at the 50s again
and repeat ourselves as some little
African nation or you know one of the
central american nations long time ago
because African countries now are much
different when we have these military
leaders coming so yes SCAF is ruling the
country ad-hoc on an ad hoc basis we're
trying to put a schedule the schedule
has been puts and I think the people are
sort of different and agreeing with with
the army
then of course people have differences
with the army they want to the army to
to relent power to the civilian
Authority the army said well okay we can
do this after we have elections of the
Parliament which is due in next month
and then after there perhaps a new
constitution and then later presidential
elections so the the Army is saying that
they will relinquish power only after
the presidential election has been
completed right deputy and I think this
is in the interest of everybody because
if you don't have any security how can
um who's going to protect the balance
for example it has to be somebody who
has the authority yeah so the
presidential election is likely to be in
September length next year is it like
well I don't think the presidential
elections we can predict when because
this hasn't been discussed ratings in
details but I wouldn't think before the
last quarter of next year I said okay so
that's kind of the current sort of
roadmap at the first the parliamentary
elections and then the presidential
election yes but but one thing in
between a new constitution we can't have
a new president without having us a new
constitution this has been also demand
of the many people in Egypt and we had
some constitutional amendments and the
referendum life if many remember on
March 19th of March seventeenth this
year so these were just certain articles
in the Constitution of course the
Constitution now doesn't fit anybody
because for example the president used
to serve for six years now we agreed
that the president is going to save for
four years with a maximum of two
successive terms things of the sort so
you need to have a new constitution that
can fit a new president without the
immense powers like before well I think
you are witnessing and we are witnessing
a historic development and you are
representing this country at this
historic moment so congratulations and
thank you for coming to yell well thank
you so much for hosting me as an honor
thank you thank you